okay so what I was saying is that
technique looks like
something but as you start to dig
deeper it's not that and in fact now I
can see it doesn't at all look like what
I thought it looked like okay so that's
how that ego tripartite mind is going to
interpret reality so it interpreted your
variations were all XY counter
opposition do you see and then you moved
like that you understood like that and
this is something totally different like
even like why would you enter on a
straight
line you know when you go under the arm
like why are you entering on the on a
126 line I shouldn't have been on a 126
line this thing's going to keep rotating
so I should enter at a right angle to
the
path that UK is on at the moment I enter
because they're going to keep coming
around do you see that and so now I'm
where you want to be in your imagine
variation of this technique
okay everything is like that
that's what happens that's what I mean
when I say that ego tripartite mind is
going to
assert everything it will do it to
everything
okay um even like for example I know you
get here and you're you're struggling
emotionally I can't I can feel it I come
in here and you're
like I could make you cry in an
instant
okay you're not you're again whatever
you think the disciplines are you can
reverse engineer
it if you're feeling like
that and you're doing them then what
you're doing is not what they
are okay
just like this technique you're stopping
the UK you're on a
126 grid you're you're on an
oppositional line of attack like that
doesn't make sense that can't be right
that can't be
iida okay so the same way if I if I'm at
an emotional state come
Friday by default I'm not doing my four
disciplines or if I think I am they've
been ered by the ego tripartite mind I'm
not doing them correctly I haven't
understood the
teaching so I know when you come here
you'd rather you want to talk right
you're all women you want to
talk you you you're taken by the
feminization of the modern world you
don't feel good you want to do talk
therapy but that isn't going
to help you you have to move your body
the talk
therapy is an uration of the
way which too much ego tripartite mind
and the ego tripartite mind is feminine
aspect of the
universe so you want to
talk but that talk therapy is based on
something that is not actually true it's
not possible it can't be right and that
is that you can divide your mind and
your
body that's not
possible and deep down you know that
just like deep down you
know staying in an XY relationship with
UK can't be iido deep down you don't
have one experience where you could ever
isolate mind from body you don't
you just have the belief that it can be
done and then you have the inertial
habitual belief that that's what we're
doing but we
don't talking is of the ego tripartite
mind and it wants to continue to
function so you women want to come and
talk about your problems you want to
come and talk your way out of it and
it's it's not going to
work you have to start
moving if you pay attention it's a it
was a short class it was small but I can
tell you're in a better spot than when
you were first here do you
see I think you have to be extra careful
when you're a woman in the way
here's the main two reasons why they're
so
profound okay one is kuga is in
essence that feminization that we have
of the
world that your what is
innately natural to you right you're
you're you're wanting to communicate
you're wanting to express your feelings
do you see if if you pay attention
the counselor therapy industry is
overwhelmingly now female
counselors and clientele female
clientele why is this natural naturally
suited to
you we we almost have the opposite
problem we have we can't get men to deal
with issues at at that level like let's
at least get it to the surface do you
see but we have a growing population of
men who do because they've been
feminized they want to talk about their
feelings and they bought into this body
mind division which is an OT
tripartite
construct it's oppositional do you
see and so we have men that don't move
men that don't lift weight men that
can't defend anything do you do you get
it I'm not sure what are
they in the traditional
sense Priscilla went
to a college campus
right I said what was it what was it
like what were the people like
like
well there's no men like Ronin or
Tristan I said what do you mean she's
all you know
like muscle bound do you get
it she's hilarious I know she was
joking but she's all I'm [\h__\h] dad I
don't I'm not going to meet a
husband but you know we're looking at
the grander scale of things do you see
in the in the Naturalization
of what is an uration of the
way so you have to
watch that you're you're in your natural
tendencies are very much consistent
correlated maybe even
causal with this normalization of what
is an uration of the way like I don't
feel good so I want to come here and
talk as opposed to I don't feel good so
I think I should do some energetic
physical component training not talk
about this
stuff that's the first reason the second
reason is
is the lessons of the way they're not
really
written for the female
gender if you look at the historical
record they are written by men about men
for
men it's just the modern
uration that holds that there's no
difference between men men and
women and so now you
read St John and you're like he's
talking to me he's not [\h__\h] talking
to
you this is why I strongly Advocate
Advocate that you read the female
saints because the technology of is
geared towards this difference in the
premodern technology there is a
difference that young is not
y we in the modern
uration we don't want
that we
want this false sameness do you
see so for example
I'm not an advocate that you guys go
crazy on your low car or even your
fasting because in my
experience it really FS up your
hormones you have to be very cautious
about what you're
doing and more
particularly that you are assessing what
is wor working and not working and how
it is working for you all along the
way I teach that to everybody so a male
should do that
too but in the
uration in a male can be
stupid and not pay attention to what
does what does carnivore you went
carnivore what's it doing for you you
see a male could be
stupid and he'll probably be
okay he might have a keto flu or
something like that you
see that's not that
bad he might have some constipation
oh you see but you
go without assessing as you're going
along the way you you go low carb you
could lose your menstrual
cycle just as an example and now what's
that do to your hormonal levels now
what's that Doe to your
mood now how well are you training
because you can't get out of bed do you
see but the uration that element one
wants to go no no no no I I I should be
able to go on keto I should be able to
go no no no no we don't probably not
that's just a simple
example if you read the Saints the
female
saints their way is not really grounded
in
the warrior sacrifice the warrior facing
of death that the the no self that comes
from that
sacrifice it's from another aspect of
the warrior this is the aspect
of devotion service the loss of self
through that
not
through go ahead
God I'll drink this cup of
poison kill me beat
me nail me to your
cross but rather
through a Divine matrimony do you see
there's a there's there is
that loss of self that comes through
the Devotion to the
marriage pay
attention just like for example if you
you can reverse engineer this
technology because we know that no self
is a process that is experienced as
suffering do you see because the ego
tripartite mind won't let go of
it so the the male
psyche right
where he he is
predisposed to no self
through
sacrifice but now look around
where do you see it how much of it do
you
see because it's
hard we don't do it we won't do
it so you can reverse engineer and go H
I don't see too many sacrificing males
anymore I mean take just take for
example
like the other day I was
telling you know Tristan is
like you you can't be a man or maybe
there was others here but it was
directed to Tristan you can't be a man
who cannot
suffer to to not be able to suffer is to
remain a
boy you they count all their wounds do
you see so in in threat assessment when
it's trained in the Secret Service model
they you know who does the shootings
they call them hurt
Harvesters they they collect you know
the active Shooters the mass murderers
they collect all their hurts that
they've had and they keep storing them
then the Secret Service colloquialism
for them is hurt
Harvester and you you psychologically
profile them and you see uh emotional
unintelligence you see a spiritual
immaturity it's a
boy in a man's
body they can't
suffer without it being so contrary to
their being do you
see whereas a mans just that's what they
do they suffer
somebody was asking me like I don't
remember which injury it was but they're
like does it is it any better and I like
well it's at the normal level of
pain you know that's zero that's the new
zero I don't have a painfree
body you but you keep going and you keep
going the kids there there's a there's a
song
faithful son and there's a line in it
where she did the singer is saying like
your kids don't know your kids don't
know what you're suffering they don't
understand that that's how it's supposed
to
be they they don't understand uh the
trials
and the hardships they're not supposed
to supposed to be able as the man you
just keep going you keep going and you
die and they never
know well you don't see that nowadays
this is too hard I'm
leaving I'm going to divorce I'm going
to get
out I'm going to get someone else to
raise my
kids to coach them to give them them
strength but in the same way we don't
see this no self technology in women
either this devotion this spiritual
marriage but that is the
way you try to suffer
you're probably going to get
crushed you do the other way you do the
Y way you're probably going to get
crushed it's probably going to destroy
you but think about it reverse engineer
if the if if the dread and and you know
the fear is related to the the
homeostatic energy of the ego tripartite
mind
ask
yourself is it not more terrifying for
you to be the devoted bride of God which
is and look at the cuga is this what
you're taught to be now no you're not
taught that level of no self you're not
taught
that you you you just look at what you
do in your normal relationships you you
try to manipulate you try to compete you
try to compare do you see and this is
not what those Saints
did and you don't have to look any
further you can stay at the West End of
the Silk
Road and you can look
at the mother of All Saints which is
Mary and you just look at her
her right and you look at what she said
thy will be
done thy will be
done so careful on how these these
things happen
right meaning careful on what your
understanding
might be a
misunderstanding and I don't mind if you
want to have some
talks or you want to talk but I want you
as dasy to go
H that is what I want to do because it's
getting away from me and this world is
telling me that's what I should do let's
move first
okay let's move first and let's release
self let's embody the thy will be done
you can you
can think about it
okay get to the heart of what any
marriage
is and you're going to find no self in
the if if it is a true marriage you're
going to find no self in
it this is why it's a Sacrament in
Catholic
ISM then add to that the spirit of the
mother of all female saints thy will be
done you can enter into that kind of no
self
commitment with the way you see with God
do you get it with with your teacher
with your training it doesn't
matter what
you
marry okay but you must stop trying
to be nailed to that
cross you must start stop trying
to wait for acts of violence to come
upon you instead you must find no self
through this D will be
done it is much harder than you think
and it's why we don't want to do it okay
it is much
harder I think it would be impossible
for me but it's possible for
you I mean it's too hard for
me but yours my my way is too hard for
you my Way's too hard for you
so careful be mindful